au salami jeunes feront dans mon
expérience la chose tomates pour la
pizza c'est la plus simple la plus
neutre possible pourquoi pas ce que je
veux pas qu'elle va à changer le goût de
mon produit final secours de pincer de
la chose que marc et après schéma
garniture qu'est ce que je veux goûter
alors je prends de tomates à cannes
moi je préfère le bruit même alors tu
prends les tomates entières peiné dans
changes où je m'ajuste un petit peu de
regards du sel du poivre de l'huile
d'accès shama chopra pizza voilà pour la
simplicité d'une sauce et pizzas selon
le chef david et bat salies
si vous décidez de vous tourner vers les
sources industrielles
nous avons demandé à sabrina à racimo
vite de faire l'analyse nutritionnelle
de 16 de ses sauces ma règle de base
pour ingrédients c est ce que ça
contient que des ingrédients que moi
j'aurais dans ma cuisine et sinon c'est
quoi les autres ingrédients pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils sont là est-ce que c'est
nécessaire et avec le sucre liquide le
glucose fructose même le sucre ajouté en
général on en a pas besoin dans une
sauce à pizza et après il y avait
d'autres ingrédients comme l'ébène soit
de sodium sorbate de potassium
alors comme on a quand même des produits
qui en contiennent pas on voit que c'est
pas quelque chose qui est nécessaire
la plupart de ces ingrédients sont
ajoutés pour la conservation ou pour la
texture
dans le cas du glucose fructose du sucre
liquide ou de l'amidon on les ajoute
pour le goût sur les seize produit
seulement trois sauces n'ont pas de
secrets ajouté soit la fab ou 10 lames
outils et les stefano on rajoute du
sucre à cause de l'acidité de la tomate
souvent section d'une tomate qui est
assez mûr tu as et sucrée on n'a pas
besoin d'ajouter du sucre lieu du sucre
naturel dans le fruit
évidemment si vous faites le tour en
épicerie vous allez voir que y'a de
sucre partout puis les gens je pense
qu'on aime sol sucre fait des fois les
compagnies y rajoute un peu plus de ce
que je sais pas ce que ça rend les gens
heureux
la sauce reste opidis par exemple
contient 12 grammes de sucre par portion
de 60 millilitres le 12 g m'a vraiment
surpris parce que ça ses proches de
certains biscuits certains céréales
sucrées les autres contiennent 3 4 5 6
grammes c'est quand même moins mais je
trouve que les tomates sont assez sucré
ils contiennent déjà dû se doit tant une
croûte de pain que c'est du sucre
j'ajoute une sauce ce qu'est sucré
ça va être juste road où on en consomme
déjà vraiment beaucoup trop dans notre
quotidien alors pourquoi on a ajouté
plus dans une sauce habitants
l'autre élément préoccupant dans les
ingrédients transformer et bien entendu
le sodium
je trouve que c'est quand même assez
élevé en particulier quand on dépasse
les 250 mg en dépasse même le 300 mg
c'est sûr qu'on va pas manger que d'un
quart de retard de la sauce à pizza faut
aussi garder en tête qu'il ya du sel
ajouté partout il ya du sel probablement
dans la côte qui a du sel dans le
fromage et en plus si on commence à
ajouter des charcuteries des sociétés
pepperoni sur notre pizza on peut
facilement avoir une pizza qui contient
le sodium recommandé pour une journée
les sauces unico basten et primo ont des
taux de sodium allant de 250 à 270 mg
par portion à 3 130 mg le clasico
contient le double de la moyenne et du
groupe
ça vous dit les canadiens et québécois
on consomme beaucoup plus de sel que
recommander la moyenne consomme et ses
proches de 3 1000 mg par jour et on
devrait rester plus proche de 1500 à
2000 mg par jour
alors si je regarde juste 1 300 mg si je
compare ça sur ma journée
1500 2000 mg tu pourrais me dire que
c'est pas tant que ça mais quand on leur
rajoute à tous les autres ingrédients à
le reste de la journée
ça peut quand même ça cumulé assez
rapidement
du côté des gras saturés la plupart n'en
contiennent pas mais on en retrouve
quelques traces dans la fabrique la
miles et les stefano la stefano contient
du fromage mais c'est tellement une
petite quantité
ça ne joue pas trop sur les calories ça
n'ajoute pas trop sur le gr on a un
petit peuple si le secret de pecorino
romano dès qu'on a un petit peu de
fromage qui va aussi devenir donné
beaucoup de goût à notre sauce ça le
prix quasiment un an avant de trouver
quelque chose qu'on aime et puis après
ça évidemment le foot je trouve la bonne
thomas mais le tout se décline par
rapport à cet ingrédient l'eau
mettre en marché un produit de qualité
sans agents de conservation est possible
selon stefano faita à cause de la
pasteurisation
on est capable d'avoir un produit sans
agents de conservation
nous on n'aime ni eau ni ce qui a
rajouté on n'a pas pas de tomates dedans
et sans gluten fait qu'à cause de ce
procédé là on est capable d'avoir un
produit qui est comme on appelle dans le
jargon alimentaire un créneau ibo après
son analyse sabrine en a fait son choix
ici j'ai tomates au sel basilique rigan
union et arômes naturels
elle avait 3 g de sucre beaucoup moins
que les autres options de grandes de
fibres en bas du 200 mg de sodium et la
pad huile ajoutée qui fait que les moins
caloriques que les autres à 25 calories
par portion
alors celle là pour moi a répondu à tous
les critères mme d'autres bons choix en
raison de leurs ingrédients simples la
stefano et la fab outils malgré son prix
plus élevé celle que moi j'ai vu que je
ne choisirai pas c'était la classique au
traditionnel à cause de la teneur élevée
en sodium
encore une fois à cause du sucre l'arrêt
stoppies 12 g de sucre et je sais qu'il
ya quand même un peu de ce qu ajouter là
dedans c'est vraiment beaucoup trop a
selon moi
nous avons remarqué une grande variété
de formats allant de 213 à 430
millilitres considérant qu'une portion
de 60 mille litres suffit pour une pizza
moyenne les petits formats sont
peut-être privilégiées
alors acheté une source tout préparés ou
la faire soi même
j'ai jamais utilisé le nouveau ça
faisait déjà tout prêt dans ma vie en
acheter des tomates on mélange un peu de
sel défaut de l'huile d'olive on mettait
un peu de rega si jamais on avait besoin
et frais on l'avait cru maintenant par
contre j'ouvre mon pot souvent si vous
optez pour faire votre sauce maison
un dernier conseil du chef david et il
faut pas que les relâche aux tomates
pour la pizza
parce que l'humilité de la chose elle va
partir très vite quand elle est étalée
sur la pâte dans le four alors si
j'ajoute on chausse déjà réduite et va
devenir trop pâteux
[Musique]